[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار الساعه
اسرائيل تتاهب في جميع الجبهات تحسبا
لهجمات بعد عمليه غزه نتنياهو يتوعد ومصر
تدخل على خط التهنئه
السعوديه تعلن استئناف عمل بعثتها
الدبلوماسيه في سوريا
بعد او وعد بوتين بنصر في ضخمه يوم النصر
بريغوجين يتراجع ويقول انه تلقى امرا
بالبقاء في باخموت والا اعتبر خائنا
وفي باكستان اعتقال عمران خان يشعل كراتشي
اشتباكات واعمل شراب تصل حتى مقر الجيش
[موسيقى]
وصلتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
جوله جديده من المعارك تلحف الافق في غزه
مع اطلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله ضد حركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه بدايه الحمله كانت
بعمليه اسرائيليه اسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه من
ابرز قاده سرايا القدس ذراع العسكريه
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في قطاع غزه
العمليه تسببت ايضا في مقتل 13 شخصا اخرين
من عائلات وجيران القاده المستهدفين
القاده الثلاثه الذين سقطوا في هذا الهجوم
هم قائد المنطقه الشماليه في الجهاد خليل
البهتيني وامين سر المجلس العسكري لسرايا
القدس جهاد غنام اضافه لطارق عز الدين
المسؤول عن توجيه عدد من العمليات في
الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
العمليه الاسرائيليه كانت عنيفه وتم
خلالها استخدام القوه بشكل واضح فبحسب
الجيش الاسرائيلي فقد شاركت 40 طائره
اسرائيليه في هذه الغارات على غزه كما ان
التخطيط للعمليه بدا منذ شهر رمضان الماضي
حيث كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرصد تحركات
قيادات الجهاز
[موسيقى]
هذا وقتلت اسرائيل فلسطينيين اثنين في
غاره استهدفت سياره جنوب قطاع غزه وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف خليه كانت
تنوي اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع
ولا شك ان التصعيد لا يتوقف عند هذا الحد
وهو ما اكده كلا الطرفين فحركه الجهاد
قالت ان ردها لا يتاخر على غارات اسرائيل
على غزه اما اسرائيل فتتاهب على جميع
الجبهات وهو ما اكده وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي الذي قال ان قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ستبقى مستعده لكل السيناريوهات
في غزه بما في ذلك الحرب المطوله من جهته
هنا وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
رئيس الوزراء بنيام نتنياهو على العمليه
الاستباقيه في غزه مشيرا الى انها بدايه
موفقه لحمله مرتقبه
[موسيقى]
المعارضه الاسرائيليه بدورها اشادت بهذه
العمليه العسكريه وذلك على لسان زعيمها
الاخير قال في تغريده له على تويتر طبعا
ان العمليه العسكريه للجيش الاسرائيلي في
قطاع غزه اغلقت الحساب مع قاده الجهات
نتنياهو قال انه اصدر تعليماته للاجهزه
الامنيه بالتصعيد وعلى اكثر من جبهه اذا
لزم الامر واشار خلال مؤتمرين عقب اجتماعي
الحكومه المصغره الى ان اي تصعيد من غزه
سيقابل برد ساح
لا يوجد ارهابي محصن اصدرت تعليماتي
بالاستعداد للتصعيد ربما على اكثر من جبهه
يجب ان نوضح لاعدائنا ان اي تصعيد من
جانبهم سيقابلوا برد ساحق اتفهم الرغبه في
استهداف هؤلاء فورا لكن علينا التمهل في
استخدام القوه كتحذير اخير نتصرف دائما ضد
اولئك الذين يسعون الى القضاء علينا ولكن
في وقت مناسب لنا اما وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي فشدد على ان العمليه العسكريه
في غزه اثبتت قوه المنظومه الامنيه واكد
ان اسرائيل مصممه على احباط اي تهديد وهي
جاهزه لاي سيناريو بما فيه معركه طويله
الامد
فور اطلاق الصواريخ على اسرائيل قبل نحو
اسبوع استعد الجهاز الامني للتعامل مع
قاده الجهاد في غزه وقمنا باستهدافهم خلال
عمليه سريعه وخاطفه من جربنا فهم قوه
اسرائيل وقوه النظام الامني نحن مصممون
على احباط اي تهديد والعمل ضد اولئك الذين
يحاولون الحاق الاذى بنا
وفي اتصال مع الوسطاء اخبرت اسرائيل كلا
من مصر وقوات اليونيفرس العامله جنوب
لبنان بانها سترد بشكل راضع على اي هجمات
عسكريه تنطلق من قطاع غزه او لبنان وفق ما
نقلت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه
واضافت القناه ان تل ابيب هددت في
الاتصالات التي اجرتها مع الوسل الطاء
هددت حماس في قطاع غزه وحزب الله في لبنان
برد رابع فيما لو قررها الرد على هجماتها
فجر اليرم
ة معنا عبر الهاتف من القاهره السفير دياب
اللوح سفير فلسطين لدى مصر ساعه السفير
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
الى اين وصلت الوساطه المصريه
بطبيعه الحال
في ظل احداث من هذا النوع
مصر تتدخل بشكل عاجل وبشكل فوري من اجل
تهدئه الوضع ووقف العدوان الذي يتعرض له
الشعب الفلسطيني سواء في قطاع غزه او في
القدس او في انحاء الاراضي الفلسطينيه ما
حصل الفجر اليوم في قطاع غزه هو جريمه
اسرائيليه تضاف الى سلسله الجرائم التي
ترتكبها قوات الاحتراق الاسرائيلي ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني وهذه الجريمه تعكس
المنهجيه العدوانيه الاسرائيليه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
وهي جريمه غير مبرره وبموادره اسرائيليه
وبدون اي سبب طالت المواطنين الفلسطينيين
مما تسبب في استشهاد 13 مواطنا فلسطينيا
وبعض الظهر اليوم ايضا تم اغتيال
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الاخرين
الشهداء كما تفضلتم خمسه عشر شهيدا في
قطاع غزه وبالتزامن ايضا كانت عمليه في
نابلس ايضا هناك اقتحام كان صباح هذا
اليوم الى مدينه نابلس وتم اعتقال
المواطنين واصابه حوالي عشر من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وفي الخليل ايضا هذه حمله
اسراريه مسعوره ضد الشعب الفلسطيني نعم
كيف تنظرون الى التصريحات الاسرائيليه
التي اعقبت هذه العمليه الدمويه
هناك حديث على ان اسرائيل سترد بشكل قوي
في حال ما اذا استهدفت من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه وهي مستعده لاي سيناريو
بما فيها الحرب المطوله
هذه التصريحات الاسرائيليه تعكس العنجهيه
الاسرائيليه والسلف الاسرائيلي بالتمادي
في مثل هذه الجرائم وكما تعلمون ان
اسرائيل حينما تلجا الى مثل هذه العمليات
وارتكاب مثل هذه الجرائم انما تريد هي
تصدير الازمه الداخليه وتوحيد الصفوف
الداخليه في ظل ما تعنيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من انقسامات ومن
معارضه لها ولبيد زعيم المعارض
الاسرائيليه يقول انه يريد ان يغلق الحساب
لا اعرف اي حساب يقصد يريد ان يغلقه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني الحساب بالنسبه لنا حينما
يغلق هو انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لارض
دوله فلسطين بشكل كامل التي ستقله لابيد
انه اغلقت الحساب مع حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
هل المواجهه هذه بين اسرائيل والجهاد
الاسلامي فقط في في غزه
ام هي حتى مع حماس ايضا
انا كدبلوماسي موجود في القاهره ليس لدي
معلومات وليس لدي علم بهذا الامر وهذا
ادعاء اسرائيلي يعني غير مثبت وغير مؤكد
وكيف يعني لشخص موجود في غزه يريد ان يصنع
صواريخ في جنين كيف سيرسلها الى جنين يعني
هذه يدعاءات اسرائيليه غير مبرره وغير
صحيحه لتبرير هذه الجريمه التي ارتكبت في
غزه بدم بارد ضد مواطنين فلسطينيين وهم
نيام في بيوتهم لذلك هم
يسوقون ذرائع وهميه لا اساس لها من الصحه
لتبرير هذه الجريمه اشكركم شكرا جزيلا على
هذه المداخله معنا من القاهره السفير
الديه باللوح سفير فلسطين لدى مصر
كشفت مصادر ومطلعه للعربيه بان القاهره هو
بمحاوله منها منع التصعيد في قطاع غزه
كانت حذرت الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه منذ
اسبوع من عمليات اغتيال اسرائيليه تستهدف
قاده فيها واضافت المصادر للعربيه ان
القاهره تقوم باتصالات موسعه حاليا لمنع
التصعيد عبر اجراء اتصالات مباشره مع
اسرائيل والفصائل الفلسطينيه بهدف تمديد
التهدئه من جهتها ابلغت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه الوسطاء انها سترد على عمليات
الاغتيال منهيه التهدئه التي تم الاتفاق
عليها قبل ايام
معي من القاهره دكتور سمير غطاس رئيس
منتدى الشرق الاوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
دكتور اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه اسرائيل اذا اغتالت في هذه
العمليه ثلاثه قاده من سرايا القدس
الجراحه العسكريه حركه الجهاد في عمليه
دمويه سقط فيها مدنيون اخرون بينهم اطفال
هل ترى اننا مقبلون على حرب مطوله في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
هل برايك القاهره الان نعم القاهره الان
يعني هي تتواصل مع الجهد الاسلامي فقط ام
هي يعني تتواصل مع كافه الفصائل بما فيها
حماس اقصد بشكل مباشر
يعني الخطوط الاتصال بين مصر وبين كل
الاطراف مفتوحه منذ فتره طويله اذكر هنا
بان الثلاثاء الماضي عندما نشبت معارك
محدوده تمكنت الوساطه المصريه من ان توقف
هذه العمليات خلال 32 الى 36 ساعه
والوساطه تاريخيا مصري هي التي تلعب
الدوري الاساسي مصر اتصالات قنواتها
مفتوحه باستمرار واذا لم يكن مباشره الان
يمكنها ان تؤثر على الجهاد الاسلامي وهو
امر كما قلت مقبول ومفهوم لكن قنوات يعني
سائر القنوات الاخرى بما فيها مع حماس
واطراف اخرى من الفصائل الاخرى في قطاع
غزه وخارق قطاع غزه مفتوحه وهذه العمليه
تجري اذكر هنا ايضا بانه الامين العام
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي كان شهر 2 الماضي
في فبراير كان في القاهره والعلاقه ما بين
الجهاد الاسلامي ومصر ليست سيئه بالطبع
ليست جيده جدا لان هناك التزامات تجاه
الجهال الاسلامي اطراف اقليميه اخرى لكنه
لم يحدث ان انتقد
الامين العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي او
تحدث سلبا على مصر والعلاقات بشكل عام هي
علاقات جيده اذكر هنا ايضا بان الشهيد
طارق كان يعاني من الام نتيجه مرض يعني
عضال وانه تلقى علاجا في السابق في
القاهره وبالتالي
المتحدث الاعلام
الضفه الغربيه الذي تم اغتياله ضمن القاده
الثلاثهم
هو اسير نعم هو اسير محرر تم نفيه الى
قطاع غزه وتتهمه اسرائيل بانه هو الذي
يدير العمليات ضد اسرائيل لانه اصلا
وتتهمه اسرائيل بانه يقف وراء الدعم
العمليات في داخل الضفه الغربي
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا دكتور سمير غطاس رئيس
منتدى الشرق الاوسط لدراسات الاستراتيجيه
كنت معنا من القاهره
ومع كل تصعيد بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه تبرز صوره مؤثره لاطفال
سقطوا ضحايا لغارات وصواريخ لا ترحم اكثر
من 2000 طفل قتلوا في غزه خلال جولات
التصعيد في السنوات الاخيره فيما ترك
الاخرون بمشاكل نفسيه كبيره حيث افادت
منظمه امميه ان 80% من اطفال غزه يعانون
من صعوبات نفسيه وهم بحاجه لمساعده
وصلت الطفله ميرال الى المستشفى تريد
اباها ولم تعلم انها صارت يتيمه ابوها
وامها قتل في الهجوم الاسرائيلي
طفله بحاجه لتدخل نفسي عاجل هي وثمانون في
المئه من اطفال غزه وفق منظمه انقذ
الاطفال الدوليه ست حروب سابقه على غزه
تركت اثار نفسيه مدمره على اطفالها الحروب
المستمره على قطاع غزه لابد ان تترك اثارا
انيه واثار بعيده المدى بالنسبه للاثار
الامنيه وخلال الساعات والايام القادمه قد
يرى الاهالي مجموعه من الاعراض تظهر على
ابنائهم الخوف الشديد نوبات من الهلع عدم
قدره على النوم او حتى تقيؤ غير مفهوم
السبب او حتى اشكال اخرى من الاضطرابات في
الجهاز الهضمي
ومعتبرت ميرال من الناجين فان علي وميار
وهاجر لم ينجو قتلته الصواريخ الاسرائيليه
وهم في فراشهم وامسوا وقود حرب لا ترحم
اكثر من 2000 طفل قتلوا خلال السنوات
العشرين الاخيره
ذنبهم الوحيد انهم ولدوا في غزه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه استئناف عملي
بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه وذلك حرصا في الاسهام في تطوير
العمل العربي المشترك وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وكذلك تنفيذا لقرار
الجامعه العربيه الاخير بشان عوده سوريا
لانشطه واجتماعات الهيئات والمنظمات
التابعه لها
معنى من الرياض الكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجاسر
اسر جاسر اهلا بكم معنا كيف تقراون هذه
الخطوه السعوديه
مساء الخير انا اعتقد ان الخطوه كانت
واضحه الملامح منذ صدور البيان
في 12 ابريل بين وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
والسوريه وحدد النقاط المتفق عليها ثم جرت
خطوات المتلاحقه في اجتماع جده في عمان
قرار الجامعه العربيه نتيجه اليقين
والتاكد من الالتزامات السوريه في تحقيق
هذه المساله لابد الان من العمل حقيقه على
تحقيق هذا التواصل المساهمه في مساعده
سوريا على الجهاز
وتطبيق الاتفاقات لابد ان يكون هناك تواصل
حقيقي وتفاعل هذا التفاعل لا يمكن يتم عن
بعد او عن طريق خطوات بعيده لابد ان يكون
التواصل حقي مباشر ومستمر والعمل المشترك
يوما بيوم ربما ساعه بساعه لتحقيق هذا
مثلا لا تحتمل الخطوات البطيئه ولا تحتمل
الاجراءات اذا كان هناك وصول الى القيام
العمل بانقاذ سوريا وهناك التزام من
الجانب السوري فلابد ان يتم العمل بسرعه
وبوتيره متسار
كما تفضلت يعني هي خطوه سعوديه ضمن
الخطوات العربيه الان والتنسيق الذي حصل
في الفتره الاخيره الاتفاق حسب مسار جده
كذلك اجتماعات جده واجتماعات عمان انه ان
يكون هناك خطوه بخطوه خطوه عربيه مقابل
خطوه من السلطات السوريه
ما الخطوه المنتظره من قبل سوريا الان من
قبل دمشق
خطوات طبعا واضحه تمام احنا يمكن بدانا
نشهد اولا يعني لنقل الحرب على المخدرات
هذه واحده من النقاط المهمه والحيويه
تحتاج الى يعني سوريا ايضا مساعده فيها
عمل من الجانب السوري ومسانده في القيام
بهذا العمل الملام الاولى هذه بدات
الخطوات ولا اعتقد ان السعوديه اعاده
العلاقات
اطم
ئنان السياق اولا مكافحه التهريب
المخدرات كامل التهريب وجود الميليشيات
الموجوده في سوريا عوده اللاجئين وبالتالي
هنا محتاجه حتى في مساعده سوريا في القيام
بالخطوات ودعم في الاستقرار ودعمها في
التنميه ودعمها في توطين اللاجئين
العائدين كلها تتطلب عمل متسارع وعمل
متواصل هذه الخطوات
او انها ستحدث وهناك مؤشر اخر
في هذه
المساله قمه في 19 مايو والتي قد يحضرها
طبعا او توجه الدعوه الرئيس بشار الاسد
فيها انها ستكون هناك خطه عمل تتضمن في
جانب منها مهم سوريا
وحقيقه لا خطوات
ننتقل الان نحن لمرحله العمليه يعني نخرج
احنا من التصورات والافتراضات لا تتم هذه
الخطوات الا بناء على التزامات وتعاهدات
واتفاقات واضحه وخطوات عمليه وهي خطوات لم
تنضج من اليومي كانت تدرس فتره طويله ويتم
النقاش حوله نقطه نقطه مثل ما تم في
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني ومن جانب في
المساله هذه مهم جدا ان نؤكد بس على نقطه
مهمه المملكه تحرس
على تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه وان يكون
هناك عمل عربي مشترك فعلا يحقق هذه القيام
بالمبادره العربيه هذه نقله في التعامل
العربي مع ملفات العربيه التي كانت تنتظر
اطراف اخرى اليوم تاخذ المبادره وتعمل من
الداخل وتحقق هذا الانجاز نعم طيب
بعد هذه الخطوه قمه جده المرتقبه وامكانيه
مشاركه الرئيس السوري في هذه القمه بعد
اعاده الان قرار السعوديه باعاده بعثه
الدبلوماسيه الى دمشق هل تطوى صفحه الازمه
السوريه
لانك فعال العمل العمل يتطلب جهد ونعرف
انها صعوبات صعوبات في الداخل صعوبات لا
يمكن المساله ليست مثلا هي ازمه لنقل مثلا
دعم فيما حدث في حدث الزلزال طبعا في نقطه
كانت مهمه ايضا تم الاكتشاف صعوبه الوصول
بسبب هذا التمزق التي تعيش سوريا نعم لابد
ان يكون هناك خطوات تحدث في الارض على
الواقع بدرجات مختلفه وفي مؤشرات معينه لا
يمكن الوصول
اذا تم الان الان اعتقد الحرب بدات على
المخدرات وهذه النقطه مهمه لان سوريا
اصبحت مركزا خطر على المنطقه في في هذا
الجانب وايضا اصبحت
بالامكانك وتواصلوا مستمر لتحقيق ذلك ونحن
فيه بعض المسائل شهور لكن خطوه خطوه انا
اعتقد اليوم ان احنا نتحرك على مستوى
خطا هناك التشريع
ولا يمكن حل الازمه السوريه بشكل
جهد كبير وايضا حتى في العمل المستقبلي في
الشارع مع المجتمع الدولي
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ جاسر الجاسر الكاتب
الصحفي من الرياض ومشاهدينا سلسله اخبار
عاجله اذا الان في ملف اخر ملف اليمن الان
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه اليمني يناقش
مع السفير السعودي جهود تجديد التهدئه اذا
في اليمن بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
هيئه قضائيه امريكيه تدين ترامب بالاعتداء
الجنسي والتشهير بكاتبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذن مشاهدينا نذهب
لمتابعه هذه الصور صور وصلتنا للتوعيه صور
متداوله لما قيل انه اعتداء او اطلاق نار
في كنيسه يهودي في جربه في تونس نشاهد
معكم هذه الصور نحاول ان نستمع للصوت
الطبيعي
اذا حسب راديو موزاييك المحلي في تونس فان
اطلاق النار هذا اسفر حتى الان عن مقتل
رجل امن في هذا الكنيس اليهودي في جربه في
تونس
لك الحديث اذا عن ان هذه العمليه ما تزال
جاريه اذا المشاهدين هذا خبر متفاعل قصه
متفاعله اذا ما تزال تتفاعل حتى الان نحن
سنلقي اعيننا عليها يبدو ان امام عمليه
اطلاق نار في كنيس يهوديه في جربه في تونس
الكنيسه اسمه كنيس الغريبه في جربه
التونسيه عمليه اطلاق نار اذا في هذا
الكنيس اليهودي تسفر عن مقتل رجل امن حتى
الان نقلا عن قناه موزاييك الاذاعيه
المحليه في تونس كما نشاهد ايضا من احدى
الشروحات هنا في داخل الكنيسه على ما يبدو
فان هناك كان هناك عدد من المتجمعين هناك
في هذا الكنيس اليهودي في جربه طبعا
وعمليه اطلاق نار هذه المعلومات اذا التي
نعرفها حتى الان اذا مشاهدينا في انتظار
المزيد من التاكيدات والمعلومات اذا
سنوافيكم بها اولا باول حول هذه العمليه
التي ما تزال جاريه الى الاطلاق نار في
كنيس يهودي في جربه في تونس الحصيله حتى
الان مقتل رجل امن نقلا عن قناه موزاييك
التونسيه المحليه
تمام
كل شيء تمام
الى تونس الان لا تزال نيران الازمه
السودانيه مشتعله في انتظار ما ستسفر عنه
الجهود الراميه في اخمادها فالازمه دخلت
يومها الرابع والعشرين دون ان يصل طرف
الصراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الى اتفاق ولو مؤقت لوقف اطلاق النار غياب
ارضيه للتفاهم ترك الوضع على حاله لتتجدد
الاشتباكات وتواصل حصد الضحايا في اخر
الاحصاء لعدد الضحايا كشفت منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان عدد القتل جراء الاشتباكات في
السودان وصل الى 604 قتله من بينهم مدنيون
كما ان القتال ادى الى اصابه ما يزيد عن
5,100 شخص نقلا عن المنظمات نفسها
وفاتوره الحروب لا تقتصر على الضحايا فحسب
بل تشمل النازحين ايضا فنقلا عن المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده فان
المعارك المتواصله في السودان تسببت في
نزوح ما يقرب من سبع مئه الف شخص لحد الان
والحصيله مرشحه من دون شك الى الارتفاع
والى جانب المعارك المتواصله على ارض
القتال تتواصل معركه تبادل الاتهامات وفي
جنيدها اتهام الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بالاستمرار باعمال نهب البنوك
والمحلات التجاريه وسرقه ممتلكات
المواطنين
عمليه النهب والسرقه باتت عنوانا رئيسيا
للازمه في السودان وهو ما تطرقت اليه
منظمات دوليه فقد ادانت منظمه الامم
المتحده نهب مجمع رئيسي لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في العاصمه الخرطوم مؤكده تاثر
وكالات الامم المتحده وجميع شركائها في
المجال الانساني باعمال النهب في السودان
ودعت المنظمه الامميه الى ضروره حمايه
واحترام العاملين في المرافق الانسانيه
بما في ذلك المستشفيات دون ان تتهم اي طرف
محدد
اضطر المدنيون في عديد احياء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الى تشكيل دوريات حراسه
لتامين منازلهم وممتلكاتهم في ظل استفحال
ظاهره السطو والنهب نتيجه التدهور الامني
الناجم عن استمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه
الدائره في البلاد منذ اسابيع الصحفيه
عمار ابو شيبه رصد للعربيه الوضع هناك
تدخل الحرب في السودان اسبوعها الرابعه
لتحدث انعكاسات متعدده على المواطنين في
كثير من انحاء الخرطوم حيث تعرضت الكثير
من الاسواق والمحل التجاريه والمنازل
للسرقه جراء امثله الامن ما دفع المواطنين
الى البحث عن حلول لتامين احيائهم
وممتلكاتهم بانفسهم بيحصل
سرقه ونهب
فهنا الحين ما شاء الله
ما قصروا يعني ارتكازات ما شاء الله على
مستوى عالي
فاغلبيه الناس البيونه من بره ويحاول على
سنهم يسرقوا الدكاكين فالناس ما شاء الله
تصدت لهم ما في دكان واحد في جريف غريب من
الحاره الاولى لحد الحاره الثانيه سرك
منطقه الجريف غرب احدى المناطق ذات
الكثافه السكانيه العاليه تجاورها محلات
تجاريه واسواق عديده تعرضت للمحاوله سرقه
ونهب من قبل اللصوص الذين استغلوا غياب
الشرطه والامن فتصدى لهم المواطلون الشرطه
ما موجوده صراحه والله الشرطه ما موجوده
لكن اولادنا قدروا يعني
انه يامنوا المنطقه من كل التفلتات
الامنيه
الوضع الامني المضطرب جعلهم يشكلون دوريات
حراسه ويجلسون لساعات طوال خشيه دخول
اللصوص للمناطق السكنيه
الحراميه الكثير وكسروا الدكاكين لحد
الاولاد يخلوا النوم كل يوم كاسرين دكان
الاولاد والله قاعدين في الشعر خلوا
بيوتهم والله
بكره الصباح قاعدين في الحته دي كان في
البدايه النبي لكن اولاد الحله
واجتمعنا كلنا وامنا دوريات
الحاجه في ظل الظروف الامنيه المعقده
والواقع المتازم بصوت البنادق والاشتباكات
العسكريه ارتفع صوت الاهالي بضروره رفض
الحرب املا بعوده الامن والحياه الى
طبيعتهما
لا للحق لا للحق
[موسيقى]
اليهودي السنوي الى هذه الجزيره اذا في
تونس
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه للعام 2023 تعد فاصله
في الحياه السياسيه التركيه والمسمار الذي
ستتخذه او المسار الذي ستتخذه البلاد في
حال فوزي او خساره اردوغان
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي يواجهوا فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
ائتلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي
اما خساره اردوغان للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه
جديده داخليا دستورا واصلاحات جديده وهو
ما تساله المعارضه من خلال الاطاحه
باردوغان بهدف دخول حقبه جديده تبدا
بالتراجع عن سياساته داخليا اي منعطف
تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني تغيرات توجهات
تركيا الخارجيه خاصه ان الدوره والتاثير
التركيين في الشؤون الدوليه يمثل تحديا
للمعارضه فهو شهاده على انجازات اردوغان
عقدان كانت الفتره الاخيره الاصعب فيهما
فقد شهدت فيها تركيا متغيرات عده اقتصاديه
على راسها التضخم وكذلك كوارث طبيعيه
زلزال كان بمثابه اختبار للرئيس التركي
لذا فان ما ستقرره صناديق الاقتراع لن
يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم لكن بكيفيه الحكم
والمسار الاقتصادي الذي سيسلكه الفائز
وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
ونتابع المشهد في اسطنبول معنى من هناك
موفد العربيه طاهر بركه طاهر اهلا بك معنا
ايضا كما استمعنا في تقرير الزميله روان
هي انتخابات مفصليه بالنسبه لتركيا تدخل
في الدوله التركيه قرنا جديدا ما الذي
لمسته حتى الان هل هناك حماسه بين الاتراك
لهذا الموعد الانتخابي
اهلا صهيب طبعا هناك حماسه كبيره الذي
لمسته من كل الذين تحدثت معهم من كل مختلف
فئات وشرائح المجتمع انه يعني هم متشددون
في ارائهم لا تلقى الكثير ممن لا يجيبك عن
سؤال من
لمن ستصوت يقولون مباشره اما اردوغان بشكل
حاسم ونهائي او كمال كليتش بشكل حاسم او
نهائي الا ان الفئه المتردده طبعا موجوده
وقد يكون لها عامل الحسم في هذه
الانتخابات النقطه الثانيه باختصار التي
لمستها عندما نسال هؤلاء انه البعد ليس
فقط متعلق بالزلزال او بالاقتصاد او بجيوب
الناس وفواتير الطاقه انما ايضا بالمواضيع
الهويه التي تؤثر في المجتمع التركي موضوع
المحافظه والتحرر موضوع الدين موضوع
القوميه والثقافه والى ما هنا عليكم نعم
ماذا عن الزلزال طاهر الزلزال المدمر الى
اي حد هو مؤثر هو حاضر في احاديث ورغبات
التصويت هل هو عامل مؤثر اكثر ماذا ايضا
عن الاقتصاد والظروف والاقتصاديه اي
الامور التي تشغل بال الاتراك اكثر
وتجعلهم يصوتون لصالح هذا المرشح او ذاك
مما تقوله استطلاعات الراي معظم استطلاعات
الراي والمحللين والمراقبين هنا انه
مواضيع الزلزال والاقتصاد على اهميتها الا
انها لا تنال الحظ والاكبر من مما يريده
الناس مع تقدم الايام الزلزال اثر في
الفتره الاولى ولكن تغير مزاج الناس بعد
كل هذه الفتره حتى بموضوع الاقتصاد يعني
الناس تعودوا على هذا الموضوع منذ اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات صحيحه ان المعارضه تقسو بالشده
وتقول وتنتقد بان الحكومه فشلت في اصلاح
الاقتصاد مع وصول تضخم الى 85% في اكتوبر
الماضي مع فقدان الليره في خمس سنوات
يعني الجزء الاكبر من قيمتها ل 80% مع
فقدان الناس لمداخراتهم مع غلاء المعيشه
والى ما هنالك ولكن من هو صاحب نزعه
متشدده مؤمن بحزبه وبتياره لا يابه كثيرا
في الواقع الا انه هذه العوامل قد تؤثر
جدا في المترد دين او في من يريد التغيير
بما ان اردوغان وحزب حكموا العشرين عاما
الان صحيح طيب طاهر على ذكر الاحزاب حدثنا
اكثر عن المرشحين طبعا في الصداره اردوغان
وكالجدار اوغلو لكن ماذا عن التحالفات
والاحزاب خلف هذين الاسمين الرئيسيين
بالاضافه الى الاسمين الاخرين
نعم بالنسبه الى التحالفات الرئيسيه كما
قلت صهيب التحالف الاساسي هو تحالف
الجمهور بقياده حزب العداله والتنميه
بزعامه رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الحالي
طبعا ويضم معه الحركه القوميه بزعامه دوله
بهجلي اضافه الى حزب الرفاه الجديد ابن
فاتح اربكان وابن نجم الدين اربكان الزعيم
الاسلامي الشهير ويحاول ان يستقطب اردوغان
من خلاله ايضا اضافه الى العامل الكردي
المحافظ المتشدد ايضا من خلال حزب الدعوه
الحره او هدى بار مرشح هذا التحالف هو
رئيس الجمهوريه التركيه الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان التحالف الاخر الاساسي هو تحالف
الامه تحالف المعارضه الذي كان احد مخرجات
الطاوله السداسيه التي كانت تضم بشكل
اساسي حزب الشعب الجمهوري بقياده كمال
كليتش دار اوبلو مرشح المعارضه مقابل
اردوغان ويضم حزب الجيد او الخير بقياده
ميرال اكشينار والتي بشده ترشيح كمال كلتش
دار اوغلو بالمناسبه اضافه الى احزاب اخرى
مهمه ولكن الاهم فيما بينها هما المنشقان
عن حزب العداله والتنميه علي بابا تشان
رئيس حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم
واحمد داوود اوغلو زعيم حزب المستقبل
وايضا يعني هذه كانت ضربه البعض يصفها
ضربه بمقتل لاردوغان وحزبه بانه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وتحالف الامه استطاع ان يستقطب
هؤلاء لكي يكسبوا الصوت المحافظ او
المتدين شكرا جزيلا لك طاهر بركه مباشره
من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
حملت محكمه امريكيه رئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب المسؤوليه على اعتداء جنسيه على
الكاتبه والصحفيه
وخلصت المحكمه المحكمه الى ان ترامب لم
يغتصب الكاتبه لكنها حملته المسؤوليه عن
التشهير بها وغرمته بدفع تعويض قدره خمسه
ملايين دولار
وفي اول تعليق الله ندد الرئيس الامريكي
سابق دونالد ترامب بحكم القضائي وصفه
بالمخزي بعد ما خلصت هيئه محلفين في محكمه
المدنيه في نيويورك الى تحميله المسؤوليه
على اعتداء جنسي وجدد ترامب على موقعه
اسوس سوشل بانه لا يعرف الكاتب ايجي كارول
التي تتهمه في القضيه باغتصابها والتشهير
بها
اخبار الساعه ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ايقاف رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان في باكستان يدخل البلاد
في دوامه من الفوضى عمليه الايقاف تمت
اثناء وصول عمران خان امام محكمه في اسلام
اباد على خلفيه تهمه فساد تقول الشرطه
باكستان ايقاف اشعل اذا فتيله الاحتجاجات
في مختلف ارجاء البلاد احتجاجات واسعه
اجتاحت باكستان عقب هذا الايقاف ما دفع
قوات الشرطه الى استخدام الغاز المسيل
للدموع وخراطيم المياه لتفريق المتظاهرين
في عده مدن ابرزها كراتشي ولاهور هذا
ودارت صدامات بين مؤيدي عمران خان وعناصر
الشرطه امام المحكمه التي اوقف بها ايضا
ونتابع مباشره من اسلام اباد مع مراسلنا
هناك عبد الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن اهلا
بك معنا هل ما تزال او ما يزال غضب انصار
عمران خان مستمرا واين بالتحديد
مرحبا بك صهيب لا يزال التوتر هو سيد
الموقف هناك انحسار ربما للمواجهات بين
انصار رئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان وقوات
الامن الاوضاع بدات تعود تدريجيا الى
طبيعتنا طبيعتها هنا في العاصمه
الباكستانيه
باستثناء بعض المدن هناك بعض النقاط
انجاز ان نسميها الساخنه لا تزال موجوده
في عدد من المقاطعات الباكستانيه
طيب عبد الرحمن اين هو عمران خان ما
المعلومات المتوفره عن مصيره هو مكان
احتجازه ايضا
وفق مكتب المحاسبه الوطني فهو يتحفظ او هو
عمران خان هو الان في لدى حمايه او لدى
معتقل لدى مكتب المحاسبه الوطني لكن لم
يعلن بالضبط عن مكانه لضبط ربما لاسباب
النيه ربما خوفا من قيام انصاره بمهاجمه
المكان من المتوقع ان يتم
عرض عمران خان امام قاضي محكمه محاسبه
اليوم الاربعاء نحن دخلنا اليوم الثاني
هنا
وخلال هذه الجلسه من المتوقع ان يطلب مكتب
المحاسبه الوطني
اعتقال عمران خان على ذمه التحقيق في
القضيه لمده 14 يوما شكرا جزيلا لك يا عبد
الرحمن المزيني من اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام عوده الى موضوع اطلاق
النار قرب كنيس يهوديه في جزيره جربه
التونسيه هذه صور جديده اذا من زاويه اخرى
من داخل الكنيس
اذاعه موزاييك اثام التونسيه قالت ان قوات
الامن التونسيه تمكنت من القضاء على قاتل
عون الامن عون الامن اي رجل الشرطه الذي
تم العثور عليه مقتولا بمركز الميناء
بعدها سمع ذوي اطلاق نار اذا في الكنيس
اذا الكنيسه الغريبه في جزيره جربه
الكنيسه اذا الذي يشهد الان موسم الحج
السنوي لليهود يعني الذين ياتون الى هذا
المعبد كونه من اقدم المعابد اليهوديه في
افريقيا او اقدمها على الاطلاق ايضا
يشهدون توافد هذا الكنيس يشهد توافدا
كبيرا لليهود في هذه الفتره في موسم الحج
السنوي
اذا ذكر اذن يذكر ان مشاهدينا ان مساء
اليوم اذا ذكر على عون امن مقتولا كما
ذكرت بمركز الميناء وسلاحه مفقود كما ذكرت
نقلا عن اذاعه موزاييك الافلام طبعا كما
نتابع في هذه الصور طبعا هناك حاله هلع
وذعر بعد سماع اطلاق نار طبعا بعد فقدان
سلاح عون الامن الذي وجد مقتولا في
الميناء وهي على ما ذكرت قناه موزاييك على
انه هو هي نقطه نقطه امنيه بالقرب من
الكنيسه لكن عندما سمع اطلاق الرصاص
كان هناك حاله ذعر اذا وهلع كما نتابع في
هذه الصور من داخل كنيسه الغريبه اليهودي
في جزيره جربه التونسيه
انا مشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي اخبار الساعه
لهذه الليله شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده
المزيد دائما على العربيه وعلى صفحاتنا
على مواقع التواصل
[موسيقى]